[MUSIC]
Good afternoon.
Thank you, thanks for inviting me.
Today I want to help all of you sell your
ideas the Steve Jobs way.
I'd like to call this the new rules of
persuasive presentations.
Because I think too, a lot of you, these
techniques will be new, or at least maybe
it's
a new way of looking at an old problem,
which is how do we sell our ideas
effectively?
As graduate students at Stanford, you all
have ideas to share.
You have ideas for new products, new
businesses, new methods, new
ways of doing things, ideas that are gonna
change the world.
Some people, are better than others at
telling their story.
Steve Jobs, for example, is an
extraordinary storyteller.
He's so exceptional, in fact, I wrote an
entire book on him.
The Presentation Secrets of Steve Jobs.
Now this book I am proud to say has become
an international best seller.
And companies around the world, companies
that
recruit from Stanford are using some of
these techniques to completely transform
the way
they communicate the vision behind their
companies.
How many of you were here when Alan
Mullaly spoke, CEO Ford, last week?
Alan called me personally last year,
called me on my cell phone,
I was actually in the gym at the time on
my treadmill.
Kind of embarrassing, I'm running out
thinking,
why is this guy calling from Detroit?
And he said, this is Alan Mullaly from
Ford, just wanna
know, I read this cover to cover, it's
really helped a lot.
So that's the kind of reaction I'm getting
from people.
But it's not just about Steve Jobs, I'm
going
to give you ideas from many, many other
communicators
who consciously or not applied the very
same techniques
when they're pitching their companies or
pitching their products.
But let's begin with a premise, I hope we
can all agree with?
A person can have the greatest idea in the
world, but
if that person cannot convince enough
other people it doesn't matter.
It's always mattered to Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs always thinks differently about
communicating the vision behind Apple.
Now what can the rest of us learn?
I learned quite a bit, techniques that I
now offer my clients.
And my clients touch your life every
single day.
From the computers you buy, to the
electronic gadgets you use, to
the foods you eat, to the medical devices
that keep you healthy.
To the cars you drive, to the gas that
goes
into those cars, and the energy that keeps
America moving forward.
My clients are in the news every day.
They improve your life every day, and they
are using these techniques, and
some of them here, [UNKNOWN], especially
which is a big client of mine,.
Recruits directly from Standford, and they
are using these techniques.
So I hope that you are a receptive
audience.
I want to teach you some of the techniques
that we use with high level executives.
Okay?
Shall I go through them?
[NOISE] The ones that apply to you
specifically, the ones that you can adopt
today.
For your very next presentation.
I'm gonna start with the most important
one [LAUGH].
Passion.
Passion is everything.
You cannot inspire unless you're inspired
yourself.
And for Steve Jobs, passion plays a very,
very important role at Apple.
In 1997, Steve Jobs returned to Apple.
After a 12 year absence.
Apple was very close to bankruptcy at the
time.
Steve Jobs held an informal staff meeting.
I'm going to show you a clip from that
meeting.
It's informal and you can tell because
he's wearing shorts.
When he really wants to dress up he'll
wear blue jeans and running shoes.
So informal staff meeting, but listen to
the role
passion would play in the revitalizing the
Apple brand.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
Marketing's about values.
This is a very complicated world, it's a
very noisy world.
And we're not gonna get a chance to get
people to remember much about us.
No company is.
And so we have to be really clear on what
we want [INAUDIBLE] to know about us.
Our customers want to know who is Apple
and what is it that we stand for?
[COUGH] Where do we get influence?
And
[BLANK_AUDIO]
what, what about us.
Isn't making boxes for people to get their
jobs done, although we
do that well, we do that better than
almost anybody in some cases.
[LAUGH] But Apple's about something more
than that.
Apple, at the core, it's core value, is
that we believe
that people with passion, can, change the
world for the better.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> People with passion.
Can change the world for the better.
This man certainly believes that.
Richard Tait was a client of mine about
five years ago.
Classic American Entrepreneur.
Sketches an idea, on the back of
an airplane napkin during a cross-country
flight.
An idea for a board game, in which
everyone could excel, in one area or
another.
Some people are better at trivia, art,
culture, music.
What game did he build?
[CROSSTALK].
Cranium.
What can Craniam headquarters?
And you are here with a wave of fun, and
enthusiasm, and engagement.
The likes of which I have rarely seen in
corporate America.
But again you need to understand that it
starts from the leader,
it starts from the entrepreneur whose
vision it was to build that company.
But what is Richard Tait passionate about?
Passion is contagious by the way.
He is passionate not so much about
building
board games, he's passionate about
building self esteem.
And it comes across in every conversation
you have with him.
And in every television interview.
Especially when he's asked a question
like, where do great ideas come from?
>> [INAUDIBLE] I, I can feel these ideas.
You just know when you're on to something.
And just don't take no for an answer.
You've just got to keep pushing, you know.
resilience and perseverance.
Those are the key characteristics of an
entrepreneur.
They can feel the idea and just don't take
no for an answer.
We [UNKNOWN] potentially when we got
sacked at first, and they
said just don't leave your day jobs you
know you're crazy.
Everyone was telling it as we were crazy.
I even called up my own dad and I said to
him I was gonna leave
Microsoft and start a games company and he
said to me, what should I tell my friends?
This is how i followed my heart.
[INAUDIBLE] in a history.
And to this day you know, I have say
to anyone is, is preserver and even feel
the idea.
You see it you know it.
Yeah, you've got your friends and you
worry about your, your friends, you know
when you get that look the test is this a
good idea or not.
And then you know you're on to something.
>> Well as so you said I'm going to put
you in one of the greatest hits big ideas,
because.
Everything you say is a [NOISE] [UNKNOWN]
form of success.
[INAUDIBLE] to the other people, don't
take no, follow your track, go for it.
I mean you just, you just get, you're the
embodiment.
I love it, love it.
[CROSSTALK] [LAUGH].
>> One thing I've learned from this show
which I saw, I, I
was watching this show every other day,
you guys were talking about customers.
[UNKNOWN] people call Craniacs.
And I've never forgotten that our
customers are our sales force.
We've sold a million games with no
advertising.
All by our customers talking about our
products, sharing those experiences.
>> By the way.
>> We sold a million games with no
advertising.
Our customers are our best sales force.
Did you see the reaction of the host?
Passion is contagious.
What I first worked with, for Richard
Tait, a colleague of
mine, said that within five minutes you're
gonna wanna work at Cranium.
Now, I didn't go to work for Cranium, but
I understand, I understand.
When I interviewed Suze Orman, who is one
of the world's great financial planners,
I asked her point blank, I said:
What makes you such an extraordinary
communicator?
She said: because I learned to appeal to
somebody's heart before their brain.
I understand what she's saying, you need
to make emotional connections with people.
You need to share what you're passionate
about.
She's not passionate about mutual funds.
Suze Orman is passionate about avoiding
the crushing financial debt that caused
so much pain for her and her family as she
was growing up.
What does Starbucks sell?
What do they sell?
>> Coffee.
So why is it that when I interviewed
Howard Shultz for a Business Week
article and a book about three years ago,
he rarely mentioned the word coffee?
I thought he was selling coffee.
Cuz that's not what he is selling, and he
was very adamant about it.
They are selling a work place that treats
people with dignity and respect.
Happy customers or happy employees equal
happy customers, what a formula.
It works for Starbucks but he rarely
mentioned the word coffee and I
said, how it, why are you talking about
coffee, that's what you sell.
He said, well sure I like coffee.
But that's not what my business stands
for.
So, you need to ask yourselves, what am I
passionate about.
And It's not the obvious.
Howard Schultz is not passionate about
coffee.
Suze Orman is not selling mutual funds.
Richard Tait is not selling board games.
And Steve Jobs is not selling computers.
He's selling tools to help you unleash
your personal creativity.
There's a big difference.
But that's the very first question you
need to ask yourself,
when you're creating the message behind
your product, or company, or service.
What is it that I'm truly passionate
about?
Now let's dig into, real techniques, that
you
can use today for your very next
presentation.
How many of you are on Twitter?
My Twitter handle is [UNKNOWN], if you
like to
follow me, I'd like to continue this
conversation with you.
How many of characters does Twitter allow?
[CROSSTALK] 140.
I think that's a great exercise.
If you cannot explain what you do in 140
characters, go back to the drawing board.
It's important, because your brain craves
meaning before details.
A neuroscientist at the University of
Washington, John Medina, taught me this.
He said, [INAUDIBLE], when primitive man
ran into a tiger.
He did not ask.
How many teeth does the tiger have?
He asked, will it eat me?
Should I run?
Big picture before details.
This is the way your brain wants to
process information.
What's wrong with this slide?
[LAUGH].
Typical slide, right?
This was delivered by a Morgan Stanley
analyst at a technology conference.
She had about twenty minutes, and she
wanted to deliver 8 big idea, 8 themes.
That's too much information.
Where's the big picture before the
details?
These actually support a broader theme.
A couple of journalists who were in the
room at the time
wrote about it much more simply, but they
focused on the big picture.
One of the headlines was, the mobile
internet is growing faster than you've
ever imagined.
Now imagine if she had come out to say,
the mobile internet is growing faster than
you've ever imagined.
And I'm gonna tell you, why?
What's more interesting, this slide which
I
created in two minutes [SOUND] or this
one?
Big picture, before details.
Steve Jobs does this all the time.
When he introduced the MacBook Air, this
could have been a very typical slide.
The average communicator would have
created the slide like this.
Today, we are very excited to introduce a
thin, lightweight notebook computer.
It has a 13 inch wide screen display,
backlit keyboard, Intel Processor.
What's the problem here?
Too much information.
What's the big picture?
In a sentence, it's the world's thinnest
notebook.
Isn't that much more interesting and
easier for
you to process than all of the details
first.
It's the world's thinnest notebook.
That's the way Steve Jobs framed it.
What do you notice about the slide.
Simple, visual, and when he delivers the
headline.
The one thing that he wants you to
remember, that's all he has on the slide.
He does this all the time.
In every presentation.
What's the iPad?
The iPad is our most advanced technology.
In a magical and revolutionary device.
That was his second slide when he
introduced the iPad.
Because that's all he wants you to
know right now, before getting into the
details.
I did notice at an unbelievable price,
they stopped using that.
This is the only time he actually used
that.
Maybe people started thinking to
themselves, 800 dollars.
That's, that's not unbelievable.
unbelievably high maybe.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But it's interesting.
That was the last time I saw it on that
one slide.
Again, Apple does this all the time.
A few months ago when they introduced The
Beatles
on iTunes, go to the website what did you
see?
The Beatles, now on iTunes.
How many of you would have the courage at
your companies.
To effectively declutter your website,
remove everything else, except
the one thing you want people to get
across.
The one thing you want people to remember.
Again, the Apple website, they do this all
the time.
It takes courage to be simple.
It takes courage to communicate simply.
If you cannot communicate what you do in
ten words
or less, a short sentence, or say, 140
characters, go back to the drawing board.
Once you give me the big picture, as an
audience member,
I need to understand the problem that
you're trying to solve.
I call this introducing the antagonist.
Because every great story, and a
presentation is a
story, every great story requires a hero,
and a villain.
So think of your presentation the same
way.
In 1984, when Steve Jobs first introduced
Macintosh.
Macintosh obviously, the Mac was the hero.
IBM was the villain.
At least in the Steve Jobs narrative.
So he actually crafted the story.
IBM would play the villain part of the
role.
Mac would come in to save the day.
IBM was a mainframe computer, at the time.
Mainframe computer maker, just getting in
the personal computers for the first time.
And Steve Jobs created this, this
presentation of
messaging around, Apple would be the only
one
to stand in, in IBM's way and make
the world safer, us creative people in the
world.
It was, it was very dramatic stuff, but he
actually crafted the narrative.
But more often than not, the enemy in a
Steve Jobs presentation is not a
competitor, or one competitor, it's, could
be a
category of problems in need of a
solution.
So, when Steve Jobs introduced the iPhone
in 2007, he didn't just point to one
villain, but a problem among all the
villains, in need of a solution.
Watch as he outlines the problem, and
offers a solution, all in two minutes.
>> Why do we revolutionary user interface?
I mean.
Here is four smartphones.
Right, the Moto Q, Blackberry Palm Treo,
Nokia E62.
The usual suspects.
And, what's wrong with their user
interface?
Well, the problem with them is really sort
of in the bottom 40 there.
It's, it's this stuff right here.
They all have these keyboards, they're
there whether
or not you need them to be there.
And they all have these control buttons
that are
fixed in plastic and are the same for
every application.
Well, every application wants a slightly
different user interface,
a slightly optimized set of buttons, just
for it.
And what happens if you think of a great
idea six months from now?
You can't run around and add a button to
these things.
They're already shipped.
So, what do you do?
It doesn't work because the buttons and
controls can't change.
They can't change for each application,
and they can't change down the road
if you think of another great idea you
want to add to this product.
Well, how do you solve this?
Hm, it turns out, we have solved it.
We solved it in computers twenty years
ago.
We saw that the big Mac screen they could
display anything we want.
Put any user interface up.
And a pointing device.
We solved it with the mouse.
We solved this problem, so how are we
going to take this to a mobile device?
What we're going to do is get rid of all
these buttons.
We'll just make a giant screen.
A giant screen.
Now, how are we going to communicate with
this?
We don't want to carry it around a mouse,
right?
So what are we going to do?
A stylus, right?
A stylus.
No.
Who
wants a stylus?
You have to hit 'em and put 'em away, and
you lose them, yuck!
Nobody wants a stylus, so let's not use a
stylus.
We're gonna use the best pointing device
in the wold, we're gonna use the
pointing device that we're all born with,
with one tab, we're gonna use our fingers.
We're gonna touch this with our fingers.
And, we have invented a new technology
called
multi-touch which is phenomenal, it works
like magic [LAUGH].
You don't need a stylus.
It's far more accurate than any touch
display that's ever been shipped.
It ignores unintended touches, it's super
smart,
you can do multi finger gestures on it.
And boy, have we had with it!
>> [LAUGH] All right.
I'm glad it stopped there.
Take a view of that slide.
We're gonna get back to something like
that.
What do you notice about those slides, by
the way?
Simple, visual.
Do you notice what he did?
He did three things.
He informed, he educated, and he had fun
at the same time.
Information.
Education, and entertainment.
All in two minutes.
I find that quite extraordinary.
Very few communicators have that skill.
But you need to begin by asking yourself,
what problem do I solve?
What problem do I solve?
What's the villain here?
And then you can offer the solution.
Enter the hero.
The solution better sell a benefit,
though.
What's the benefit behind it?
People want to know, what's in it for me?
I learned this in journalism 101.
I went to UCLA.
Went to Northwestern to study journalism,
then I went
to CNN and some other media outlets after
that.
But I learned this my first day of
journalism school.
What's in it for me?
Why do I care?
Let me show you an example of how we sell
the benefit in some of my clients.
At CES this year, Intel launched a new
micro
processor, it's called Sandy Bridge,
that's the code name.
Sandy Bridge actually, is the largest,
biggest technological leap in Intel's
history.
It's a big deal for Intel, and it's a big
deal for consumers.
Here's the technical definition.
Sandy Bridge is based on the 32 manometer
manufacturing process.
It's processing cores feature hyper
threading and turbo boost technology.
Are any of you inspired and excited about
running
out today to buy one of these new
computers?
Yeah.
Good, he gets it.
That's powerful stuff though.
That's actually technology that's going to
improve your life significantly.
But I don't see too many hands and
nobody's interested yet.
Okay, let's try this.
What if you walked into a Best Buy and
somebody said something
like think of the micro processor as the
brain of your computer.
Now with these Intel chips you get two
brains in one computer.
It's the fastest chip on the market.
What does that mean to you?
Video games, will look amazingly
realistic.
You'll be able to transfer video and
upload it to YouTube much more quickly.
In fact, what took four minutes to encode
will now take 30 seconds.
And finally, it's much more energy
efficient.
That means you'll get much longer battery
life.
So the next time any of you are looking
for a new
computer, do you think you're gonna ask
for this new generation Intel processor?
Do you think you'll want it now?
Yes.
Yeah.
More hands.
Why?
I just, I, what I told you earlier is
exactly the same thing.
It was exactly the same thing, but I
changed the messaging.
Instead of focusing on the chip and its
features, what would the features do for
you.
Sell the benefit.
Introduce the hero which is your product,
your service, your company, but you
better tell me why I need it and how it
will improve my life.
What was the big question when Steve Jobs
introduced the iPad?
A lot of people were skeptical.
They said, they asked themselves well why
do I need another device?
I have a smart phone and I have a laptop.
What's in it for me?
Steve Jobs gave us the answer.
>> There's laptops.
And smart phones now.
Everybody uses a laptop in the work
circle,
and the question has arisen lately is
there room
for a third category of device in the
middle?
Something that's between a laptop and a
smartphone.
And of course we've pondered this question
for years as well.
The bar is pretty high and in order to
really create a new category of devices,
those devices are gonna have to be far
better at doing some key tasks.
In order to be far better at doing some
really
important things better than a laptop,
better than a cell phone.
What kind of tests?
Well, things like browsing the Web.
Now, that's a pretty tall order.
Something's better at browsing the Web
than a laptop?
Okay.
Getting email.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Enjoying and sharing photographs.
Watching videos.
Enjoy your music collection.
Playing games.
Reading Ebooks.
If there is going to be a third category
device it is going to have
to be better at these kinds of tasks than
a lap top or a smart phone.
Otherwise it has no reason for being.
Now, some people have thought Apple's
Netbook.
The problem is, Netbooks aren't better at
anything.
[LAUGH] They, they're slow, they have low
quality
displays, and they run frumpy, old PC
software.
So they're not better than a lap top at
anything, they're just cheaper.
They're just cheap lap tops and we don't
think iii.
But we think we've got something that is.
And we'd like to show to you for the first
time.
And we call it the iPad.
So, let me show it to you now.
This is what it looks like.
I
actually
have one right
here.
>> He always just happens to have one
right here.
[LAUGH] He informs, he educates, and he
entertains.
When's the last time you laughed at a
presentation or had fun with it?
That takes courage, but it also takes
thought.
You need to answer the question before you
even open your slides, why should my
audience care?
Because that's the only question on their
minds.
They don't really care about your
technology or your features.
Or the commission that you need to make.
They don't care about any of that.
They just wanna know what's in it for me.
Why should I care?
Answer that.
Don't leave them guessing.
Now I know many of you, at least the first
years, unless I'm mistaken, are taking a
lot of quantitative courses.
That true?
Yup, a lot of heavy financial courses this
year.
Let's talk about something then.
Bringing numbers to life.
Steve Jobs will rarely introduce a
datapoint, a statistic
without putting it into some kind of
context that people can understand.
So for example in 2001 when Steve Jobs
introduced the iPod
for the first time he said it had five
gigabytes of storage.
Five gigabytes of storage.
I mean I know what is it today many of you
might have purchased the latest one, 160
gigs or something like that?
But it was five gigs in 2001.
What does that mean to anybody?
Five gigabytes of storage, okay?
That's not that interesting, I'm not even
sure what it means.
Oh, it meant 1,000 songs.
Storage capacity for 1,000 songs.
Now it's more interesting, but Steve Jobs
goes one step further.
It's 1,000 songs in your pocket.
Now I'm in interested.
Now I'm inspired.
Steve Jobs does this all the time.
As do all the other executives at Apple.
I've seen many other presentations as
well.
It's very affective.
Don't just throw out a big number without
putting it into
some kind of context that is relatable to
me and my life.
Cisco has the same type of challenge.
Cisco makes big routers and switches that
nobody ever sees so they've become
very good at putting big numbers
into perspective and making them very
interesting.
Last year, Cisco released a CRS3 router.
Capable of handling 322 terabytes per
second.
It's a big number isn't it.
Not very interesting, just sounds like a
big number.
So, when John Chambers, the CEO, was
giving presentations on
it, in every presentation, and in every
interview, he rarely
even used the number 322 terabits, but he
did say
powerful enough to stream every movie ever
made in four minutes.
Powerful enough to download the entire
Library of Congress in one second.
That's interesting.
That actually got picked up by a lot of
mainstream
press who otherwise would have no business
covering a Cisco router.
But he made it interesting.
Put numbers into perspective.
Bring numbers to life.
I just want to introduce that concept for
you because I know a
lot of you are taking those sort of, those
classes in your first year.
What have I been doing in the last few
slides?
I've been trying to keep them as simple as
possible and as visual as possible.
When you are creating slides it helps to
think visually.
How many of you give PowerPoints, create
PowerPoints, how many of you use
PowerPoint?
Everybody.
How many of you use Apple Keynote?
Okay.
A few of you.
It's a beautiful program.
Very refined program.
All my clients use PowerPoint.
97% of us use PowerPoint so I tend
to use PowerPoint as well for
compatibility reasons.
But this goes beyond PowerPoint.
I have seen really awful keynote
presentations as
well I, so I don't think it's some
much the presentation software as much as
it
is how to tell the story using the
software.
I think what happens is Microsoft and
PowerPoint
sort of make it easy to be mediocre.
This is what it does.
It forces you to create a title slide and
then add bullets
and more bullets and sub bullets until you
are really in the weeds.
[LAUGH] And oh, there, there's empty
space.
We can't have that.
So, let me add some cheesy clip art.
And, you know I'm an MBA, so I need to add
a chart and a squiggly
line, and there you have it the worlds
ugliest slide at least, so I
thought when I first created that slide,
until I saw this [LAUGH].
That's a real slide.
This was delivered in the US, among the US
military commanders.
And one general actually said, he actually
said this, if
I can understand this slide, we'll have
won the war.
[LAUGH] So, I thought I could make a
really
bad PowerPoint, when I wanted to, but this
stops it.
There's no way I can compete.
That is a bad Powerpoint slide.
What's the difference?
The difference is that a slide in a
Steve Jobs presentation simply complements
the messenger, its Steve
Jobs telling the story, Steve Jobs is the
narrator, think of the sort of a broadway
play.
Because he is very theatrical.
Steve Jobs is the central figure.
The narrator.
The slides are in the back drop.
That's all they do.
It serve to compliment the story.
The average PowerPoint slide has 40 words.
It is difficult to find 40 words in ten
slides in a Steve Jobs presentations.
You will get words and text and images as
well.
There's a reason for this whether he's
doing this consciously
or not neuroscientists will tell
you there's something called picture
superiority.
It simply means that when information is
delivered.
Verbally, people will remember about 10%
of the information.
Add a picture or an image, retention goes
up to 65%.
In fact, too many words on slide is
actually very difficult for the
brain to process because, according to
John Medina who I talk to.
The brain interprets every letter as a
picture, so
what happens is the brain is literally
choking on text.
Now, some of you, the more thoughtful
ones, the
smart MBAs are thinking to themselves well
I can read.
It doesn't bother me when I'm reading.
Yeah now try reading, and have somebody
else talk to you at the same time.
Can you process both?
No.
So, why do we expect people to do so when
we're giving PowerPoint presentations?
Let's create wordy slides with a hundred
words on them, and I'm gonna tell
you something really complicated, and I'm
gonna
expect you to concentrate on either one.
It doesn't work.
What does Steve Jobs do?
Let me create, let me create a really ugly
slide around the Macbook Air.
This, I think, would have been a typical
slide, but,
again, after looking at that other
PowerPoint, this looks like genius.
Those of you who are looking at
this closely can tell there's different
fonts sizes,
different sizes of shapes, there a little
clip
art, because, God forbid we have empty
space.
This gives you all of the details about
the Macbook Air.
Well when Steve Jobs and his team were
trying
to decide, how do we communicate the
vision behind
this computer in a way that everybody's
gonna remember,
and how do we do that in the slide?
They came up with this.
It's so thin, it fits inside one of those
envelopes.
Why do we need any text on that?
What's more interesting?
What's more memorable?
This or that?
But this takes thought.
See this doesn't take a lot of thought.
This you just throw a bunch of words on
the slide.
That takes, practice, thought, research
ahead of time.
So think, visually.
And in order to think visually guess what,
you've
got to start like this, sketching, brain
storming, white boarding.
Before you open up the slides.
Visual slides help in creating what's
called a holy smokes moment.
This is that one moment in a presentation
that everybody's going to remember.
Everybody remembers when Steve Jobs pulled
the Macbook Air, out of the envelope.
At least everybody who is was in the
audience that day.
John Medina taught me, he said Carmine,
the
brain does not pay attention, to boring
things.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So don't make it boring.
When the brain detects, an emotionally
charged event.
Anger, fear, surprise.
It actually releases DOPAMINE in the
system, acting
as a mental post-it note, saying remember
this.
Create that one moment of surprise.
Steve Jobs did, so when he introduced the
iPhone.
He could have come out.
And said hey, we're really excited today
to introduce this new technology.
It's Apple's new smartphone.
First time, Apple has created a phone, I
can't wait to tell you about it.
Yeah, he could have done that.
Most people would have.
Instead, Steve Jobs did this.
>> Today, we're introducing.
Three revolutionary products of this
class.
[SOUND] The first one is a wide screen
iPod with touch controls.
[SOUND] The second
is a revolutionary
mobile phone.
[SOUND] And the third, is a breakthrough
internet communications device.
[SOUND].
So three things.
A wide-screened iPod with touch controls,
a
revolutionary old phone, and a
breakthrough internet communications.
An iPod, [COUGH] a phone, [LAUGH] an
internet communicator.
An iPod, the phone.
Are you kidding me?
These are not three separate devices.
This is one device.
[NOISE] And we're calling it iPhone.
[INAUDIBLE] Today, today Apple is going to
reinvent the phone.
>> Pretty entertaining, isn't it?
What's the Twitter friendly headline from
that presentation?
Today Apple reinvents the phone.
That was on their press release, on their
website, and in the presentation.
What's the one thing you want me to
remember?
When you create visual presentations or
you think about how to move away from
the slides in order to create these
emotionally charged events, it helps to
think
about it this way what's a multi sensory
experience I can create that has
absolutely nothing to do with the slides
sometimes the most memorable parts of a
presentation.
Are not about what's on the slide, and yet
we spend 98%
of our time getting the fonts just right
and the right images.
Often times we gotta think about how to
connect with people beyond the slide.
Bill Gates has been doing a very good job
of this.
Bill Gates is now the world's largest
philanthropist,
and he has the challenge of talking about
global problems, very complicated
problems, in simple to
understand language, which has been doing
very, very well.
Last year he gave a talk about reducing
childhood deaths in Malaria.
The most memorable part of his
presentation, one that
went viral, had nothing to do with his
slides.
Although the slides were beautifully
created, they were very visual.
A lot of images.
Very powerful slides.
But the most memorable part of his
presentation was multi sensory.
It went beyond the slides.
>> For example, there's more money put
into baldness drugs than are put into
malaria.
Now baldness is a terrible thing [LAUGH]
and rich
men are afflicted [LAUGH] and so that's
why that.
[COUGH] priorities.
[INAUDIBLE] 18 million deaths a year
caused by Malaria.
Greatly understating its impact.
Over 200 million people [INAUDIBLE] can't
get the economies
of this areas going, because it holds
things back so much.
Now malaria is transmitted by mosquito's I
brought some
[INAUDIBLE] let them roam around the
auditorium a little bit.
[LAUGH].
There's no reason only poor people should
have malaria.
>> [LAUGH].
>> But those mosquitoes are not.
>> Yeah, he was going to say, those
mosquitoes are not infected.
I'll say, that is astonishing.
He created a multi-sensory experience.
It was a memorable experience, and he got
people to laugh
about a serious subject like malaria, but
he made it memorable.
And I know as a fact that he's always
thinking, about how
to communicate these very difficult issues
in a way that people can understand.
Now there's one other topic I just want to
introduce to you briefly.
I'm not gonna go into it.
We could do a whole half day workshop on
this, but we're not going to today.
I just want to introduce it to you because
it's important.
You can have all these things.
You create a great PowerPoint
presentation, great
messaging, you've got a hero and a
villain.
But you have it to deliver well.
You have to deliver effectively.
This is called mastering stage presence.
Great communicators all have great
presence.
This is an important statistic, 65%, 65%
of the impression that
you leave on someone has little to do with
your message.
It has to do with your facial expressions.
Your verbal delivery, your body language.
There are three things that you can do
today, that will help
you stand out from the vast majority of
public speakers and communicators.
Number one, eye contact.
Make eye contact 80, 90% of the time.
That's why I don't like it when people
have too many notes to read from.
Where if you put too many words on the
slide, you're breaking eye contact.
Steve Jobs rarely breaks eye contact.
He will turn to a display, bring something
up, and turn back to the audience.
Open posture, open simply means there's
nothing in between me and you.
If I had delivered this presentation
exactly the same way, but I had done
so like this, the whole time, would that
have left a different impression on you?
Why?
It's the same content?
Because 65% of the impression I'm leaving
on you, has little to do with the content.
And also hand gestures.
Use hand gestures.
I'm Italian, so it's easy for me to use
hand gestures.
But it's okay.
Researchers are finding that complex
thinkers use complex gestures.
A lot of people will ask me what do I
do with my hands, do I keep them in my
pocket?
Take them out, be animated.
Be animated in voice and in body.
And finally, let's wrap all this together.
Never forget that you are selling dreams,
not
products, because your customers do not
care about your company.
They don't care about your product or
your serviced, but they do care about
themselves.
Their hopes, their goals, their dreams,
their ambitions.
Help them achieve their dreams and you'll
inspire them.
You'll win them over.
Steve Jobs has always been in the business
of selling dreams.
When he first got together with Wozniak in
the spare bedroom of his parents house in
1974.
That's actually where it started, not the
garage, they were just playing with
electronics.
And Steve Jobs had a vision.
He said, I would love to make computers
that are easy to use for everyday people.
He was always selling dreams.
In 1997, remember that I told you that he
had
returned to Apple, after being away for
about 12 years.
He returned to Apple.
In his first major presentation the
following year, he
paused at the end of his presentation and
reminded people.
Of what Apple stood for as a brand.
It's very powerful moment.
>> I want to talk just a little bit about
Apple and the brand and I
want to use I think to livest.
You know, I think it always has to
be a little different, to buy an Apple
computer.
When we shipped the Ap 2, you had to think
different about computers.
Computers were these things you saw in
movies.
They occupied giant rooms.
They weren't an extension on your desktop.
You had to think differently, because
there wasn't any software at the
beginning.
You had to think differently once the
first computer arrived at school.
What I've never been on before is an Apple
two.
I think [INAUDIBLE] when you bought a Mac.
It was a totally different computer,
worked a totally
different way used a totally different
part of your brain.
And it opened up a computer world for a
lot of people who thought differently.
You were buying a computer [INAUDIBLE]
one.
Now I think you still have to think of
[UNKNOWN].
And I think that people do [UNKNOWN] do
think
that way and they are the [UNKNOWN] in
this world.
They are the people that are not just out
to get a job, they're want opportunity to
grow.
And they're opportunity to grow [UNKNOWN]
whatever great tools they can get.
And we make tools for those kinds of
people.
So hopefully what you've seen here today
are some
beginning steps that [UNKNOWN] confidence
that we too are
are going to think differently, and serve
the people
that have been buying our products since
the beginning.
A lot of times people see crazy, but in
that crazy,
we see genius [INAUDIBLE] thank you very
much.
[NOISE].
>> How can you not be inspired by that.
But you see what he's doing, he's focusing
on the
customer, and their needs and their hopes
and their goals.
He's always thinking differently about how
to
communicate, and articulate the vision
behind his products.
He's not just selling computers.
And now, in true Steve Jobs fashion, those
of you who
have seen Steve Jobs' presentations know
that he always ends with.
One more thing.
That one thing that typically's the most
important product introduction.
Let me just leave you with that one more
thing today.
Don't let the bozos get you down.
There will always be naysayers and
skeptics, and people who
don't believe in your idea or believe in
your dreams.
Don't let them dissuade you.
Imagine what one young man must have
thought
when he heard things like, we don't need
you.
You haven't gotten through college yet.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Get your feet off my desk, get out of
here, you stink, and we're not gonna buy
your product.
Or there's no reason why anybody would
want a computer in their home.
As you can guess by now Steve Jobs heard
all of these things.
Didn't stop him.
When a Disney executive who's role it was
to revitalize the
Disney stores asked Steve Jobs for advice
Steve said dream bigger.
That's my advice to you.
Dream bigger.
So that's my advice to you folks today.
Dream bigger, see genius in your
craziness, believe in yourself, believe in
your
ideas, and above all, deliver and
communicate
those ideas with confidence, clarity, and
passion.
Because it's those ideas that are going to
change the world.
Thanks for inviting me to spend your, the
lunch hour with you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[NOISE]